this year's sinful cup is the strongest
test tournament ever it's the strongest
tournament in history the strongest
chess tournament in history the
strongest chess event in the history of
the game the biggest chess tournament of
all time what is the singfield cup which
starts tomorrow it is an international
tournament i reluctantly agreed to let
them call the tournament that
karu nakamura
how'd i do
very well i got it done is one of the
greatest players in the world ranked
fifth is that correct that is correct
how many how many moves would it take
for you to beat me uh maybe 10 moves in
saint louis the new chess capital of
america 22 year old fabiano caruana just
won seven straight games against the
strongest field of competitors in any
chess tournament maybe ever what's
really incredible is that 22 year old
prodigy fabiano caruana won his first
seven matches in a row meaning he took
down the number one player in the world
the number two player the number seven
player and twice beat the number six and
number nine players in the world the
prestigious event is all happening in
the heart of the city you're going to
see the best chess in the world right
here in st louis at the chess club in
scholastic center of st louis so it's a
pretty amazing thing to happen going on
now in st louis through september 7th
there's the sinkfield cup the world's
top player magnus carlson is there he's
the defending champ he faces most of the
other top 10 players in the world st
louis is home to the chess hall of fame
the lebron james of chess a guy named
magnus carlson of norway how old is he
and what makes him so good
um boy i wish i knew what made him so
good so that i could do it um has there
been a handshake yes there has been
you